vous faire découvrir aujourd'hui le
festival à pas contés avec simon lépine
vous lisiez tout à l'heure c'est à
destination des enfants mais aussi des
plus grands
tout à fait c'est aussi à destination
les plus grands d'ailleurs on observe
depuis quelques années de plus en plus
d'adultes qui viennent sans leurs
enfants sur le festival
alors cette année c'est à 75% autour des
marionnettes racontez moi
en fait on s'est rendu compte que dans
la tête des gens l'art de la marionnette
était encore cantonnée à l'image un peu
vieillotte de guignol et on souhaitait
lui redonner un peu ses lettres de
noblesse et vu qu'on est il ya peu
d'opérateurs qu'ils le font sur le
territoire de bourgogne franche comté on
s'est dit que c'était peut-être
l'occasion de faire un petit focus sur
la marionnette sur cette 20e édition
alors le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
que vous avez invité des compagnies qui
sont particulièrement en vue on va voir
quelques photos
à commencer par vent debout on va pas
faire le catalogue de tous les
spectacles
le plus simple c'est d'aller faire un
petit tour sur internet de taper à pas
comptés dans tous les bons moteurs de
recherche y retrouve évidemment tout ça
mais ça en quelques mots vent debout
donc vent debout en fait c'est un peu
sur le l'histoire de l'expression c'est
comment faire passer des messages des
fois quand la communication est rompue
on va devant vous vous osez dire qu'avec
nos enfants ça peut parfois être un peu
tendu jean-jacques nicolas non ça arrive
assez réaliste ou une autre une autre
belle soirée ça sera par exemple
rick d'un eric dont alors et darick dont
la c1 conques et revisiter ce qui nous
tenait à coeur dans ce spectacle c'est
que c'est la grande île cash online une
danseuse et marionnettiste allemande en
fait qui à l'origine de ce spectacle est
la particularité c'est que les
marionnettes sont des prolongements de
son corps on retrouve évidemment toutes
les palettes du spectacle vivant si je
vous dis par exemple possession alors
possession là on est sur une forme un
peu atypique qui mélange la marionnette
et la magie nouvelle c'est ce qu'on voit
là tu as fait la particularité c'est
qu'on voit absolument jamais le
manipulateur
donc on a l'impression que tout s'anime
un peu par magie c'est incroyable ça
c'est incroyable ça c'est sûr y'a un an
et un peu terrifiant mais bon il y en a
pour les jeunes les plus jeunes et les
moins jeunes tout à fait est là pour
tous avec des représentations qui dure
en moyenne une heure c'est ça alors une
heure faut les plus grands 30 minutes
pour les plus petits
cette année le spectacle pour les plus
petits on commence à partir de 18 mois
avec un spectacle qui est plus dans le
ressenti et et qui permet de beignets
les enfants dans un univers un peu fait
très découvrir comme on tisse des liens
entre entre les générations on va voir
un autre spectacle
regardez par exemple babil c'est aussi
étonnant donc là c'est de la marionnette
de papier donc quand je vous disais
qu'on explorer un peu toutes les
différentes formes de marionnettes là on
a eu un exemple où c'est que des
marionnettes de papier de et les petits
magnette en fait que les deux
manipulateurs ont déplacé sur les fils
et les panneaux pendant leur
présentation et aussi ficelles que moi
j'ai sélectionné parce que j'ai trouvé
ça sympa fils elle avait regardé donc là
c'est un petit personnage donc fait en
bout de ficelle et s'est mêlé avec de la
musique fait en live donc avec des
instruments traditionnels dont des
calebasses comme on peut le voir sur le
sur l'image ou bien encore gaïa là la
particularité c'est que on va rentrer
dans un dispositif qui a un ancien
camion de pompier qui a été reconvertie
en salle de spectacle et donc qui sera
installée dans le jardin du musée de la
vie bourguignonne à dijon mais attention
jeu de mouret dit maître capello
la valse et des omelettes derrière avec
les allées les omelettes h o2feel à et
pourquoi
la valse des hommes il est avec ce lapin
parce que là en fait on visite un conte
de grimm avec donc aux différents
personnages est à noter qu'il ya 13
heures sur le cadran est donc à la
treizième heure en fait les lutins en
font un peu qu'à leur tête et donc c'est
la valse de tout ces petits bonshommes
qui vont investir le plateau avec un
univers graphique très marquée d'un
artiste qui s'appelle patrick simpson et
puisqu'on parle d'artistes une belle
artiste qui est une compagnie c'est abou
breitman
on pense à l'actrice à la réalisatrice à
la metteur en scène a lu des césars et
les molières
ce qu'on sait moins c'est qu'elle a
chanté avec arnold turboust adélaïde et
moi j'adore cette chanson voilà pourquoi
en parler et à la plaque qui vont aller
chercher un petit peu sur le net ça va
pas nous rajeunir ses les années 80 mais
abou breitman à la une compagnie de
marianne et moi je ne savais pas c'est
quoi explique alors alors c'est pas de
la marionnette là on est plus sûr du
théâtre un peu plus traditionnel mais
c'est sa toute première production jeune
public en elle le sait que du théâtre
pour adultes est donc là elle a décidé
de monter une compagnie qui sape
cabotine spécialement dans la production
jeune public où ça va être l'histoire
d'un chien vagabond errant qui parle le
chat qui chante et d'une petite fille
est donc cette histoire en fait de deux
personnages qui ne parlent pas le même
langage qui vont finir par se comprendre
quand même mais vous savez quoi nous on
se comprend très bien
thelonius et lola on va regarder un tout
petit extrait c'est la compagnie zabou
breitman c'est dans le cadre du festival
à pas contés ça se passe actuellement en
bourgogne franche comté dans les
environs des gens regardez je m'appelle
yola des vénus enchanté
j'ai pas voulu juillet je vous donne la
patte
avec plaisir par lesquels mangue
nous parlons chien nous utilisons la
grammaire du poil
la grammaire du poil et seuls deux
narines
la conjugaison est un peu difficile on
confond parfois le frisson d'une
moustache avec la cram de l'oreille
thelonius et lelas par la compagnie
zabou breitman l'un des multiples
spectacles qu'on peut découvrir dans le
festival à pas contés ses 80 une
représentation s'est dit création ses 24
spectacles ces quinze lieux ça rayonne
sur le grand dijon ça existe depuis 20
ans donc que de faire le catalogue allez
donc faire un petit tour pour découvrir
cet événement ça se passe jusqu'au 28
février donc il reste encore un petit
peu de temps pour s'y rendre
un petit peu de temps il est un petit
peu de classe mais plus beaucoup il faut
se dépêcher
oui parce que pour être très clair y
avait environ 10000 places c'est
simplement 8000 places et là il y en a
un peu plus tôt un peu plus de 8000
devant du doigt tant mieux mais très
bien félicitations et bravo à ce
collectif à la baisse-- organisateurs de
cet événement festif et populaire en
bourgogne franche comté un festival à
destination des enfants mais pas
seulement je le redis ça c'est important
pour les parents et les grands parents
qui sont avec nous